hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in the conclusion to part three of
his pra to any future metaphysics one of
the topics that K is going to begin to
explore that's really quite fascinating
is what it is that reason is actually
about and he's not going to engage in a
full critique of pure reason or
practical reason those are other works
but he is going to dwell on why it is
that we cannot get away from the
transcendental ideas altoe we can't just
push them off and say ah we can't know
anything about those sort of things why
are we as rational beings inevitably
drawn in to thinking about these matters
so another way of framing this given a
term that Kant is going to use why can
we not simply leave numina completely
aside and stick to just the phenomenal
World in you know what we're going to
see later on as the project of a school
that is called
positivism so what we're looking at here
is the completion and
satisfaction of Reason which is a
completion and satisfaction for
ourselves as rational beings
accompanying K on this this journey
through the proma so he's got this great
line where he's going to say uh that
begins here um we cannot beyond all Poss
experience form a definite notion of
what beings and themselves may be yet we
are not at Liberty to abstain entirely
from inquiring into them why
experience never fully
satisfies reason now the terms that he's
using there he says fig gug so it's it's
more of a noun than a uh verb you never
attain a complete satisfaction action uh
on reason's part right from
experience but in answering questions
refers us further and further back and
leaves us
dissatisfied
unict right so there is no
be with regard to their complete fig
solution and so he says this anyone May
gather from the dialectic of pure reason
which we're going to talk about in just
a bit but notice the idea here we have
completion which we've already seen
plays a massively important role earlier
on in this section and
satisfaction an affective term right and
what's really remarkable about this
section is that Kant is not going to use
emotion language but he is going to use
the language of a broader affectivity
reason has desires or longing reason
wants right so this is quite important
and then he's going to talk about the
dialectic of pure reason as having shown
this to us and he's going to you know
talk about the psychological and
cosmological and Theological ideas why
do we have to engage with these
he says who can refrain from asking what
the soul really is and if no concept of
experience suffices for the purpose from
accounting for it by a concept of Reason
though we can't prove its objective
reality so we're stuck right we can't
not think about the soul there are other
options right we can dismiss it ah
there's no such thing as a soul we can
be materialists we can uh you know have
other ways of of rejecting it but KH
says that the those aren't really going
to satisfy us but our concept of the
Soul isn't going to satisfy us either
and then he talks about who can satisfy
himself with mere empirical knowledge in
all the cosmological questions about you
know the nature of the universe its
extent or Freedom or natural necessity
and he says notice that each of these
answers raises new questions we don't
find a resting place in them and then
finally in the ideal of pure reason the
theological idea who does not see in the
thoroughgoing contingency in dependence
of all his thoughts and assumptions on
mere principles of experience the
impossibility of stopping there so we're
we're confronted with a problem
and
interestingly Kant is going to talk just
a uh little bit earlier about the end
and use of our reason right reasons end
and use is what leads us
into metaphysics so there's a purpose a
goal to reason it's one that reason
itself can uncover for itself and reason
can regulate its own use its own nutsen
right so how is this actually going to
work and why is it that metaph physics
is going to lead us into this he says
metaphysics and its fundamental features
perhaps more than any other science is
placed in Us by Nature itself and cannot
be considered the production of an
arbitrary choice or casual enlargement
in the progress of experience from which
it is quite separate disparate right so
he says reason with all of its Concepts
and laws of the understanding those have
been outlined earlier in the work and
are outlined in the critique of pure
reason are adequate H Ren going far
enough for empirical use great so if
we're looking at things within the world
if we're doing uh pure mathematics or
even pure Natural Science wonderful
right those are uh not empirical
Sciences but they are ultimately of
things that are met with in experience
and here K says there is however no s
isfaction no be no resting in being at
you know a completed State we could say
finds for itself No
Satisfaction why because of and he uses
two different terms here because ever
recurring questions deprive us of all
hope of their notice
complete solution right so completion is
also built in here and then he talks
about about uh problems he says the
transcendental ideas which have that
completion in view right um are such
problems of reason so we have questions
we can't we can't answer all the
questions in part because new questions
arise and we have larger problems which
are the transcendental ideas themselves
so he goes on and he says that the
sensible World cannot contain this
completion this you know being brought
to its Perfection or its finality
however you want to understand fendy
kite right so it's not just the sensible
World itself it's also as he says the
concepts that we uh grasp in terms of
space and time and even the pure
concepts of the understanding like the
categories they don't give us a
completion that we are inevitably as
rational beings through our faculty of
Reason seeking out so we remain
unsatisfied even when we're satisfied
with one part we're like that's good
this is excellent over here it's just
not everything I was looking for so why
he says the sensible world is nothing
but a chain of appearances connected
according to universal laws as that it's
wonderful but it doesn't have any
subsistence by itself it is not the
thing in itself and consequently now
notice this
consequently must point to that which
contains the basis of this appearance to
beings which cannot be cognized merely
as appearances but as things in itself
now we can say well why does why do
these empirical matters connected
together in such Myriad cool ways that
we've you know outlined
before why do they have to point Beyond
to something and if we're really being
strict about this they don't Point
Beyond Reason looks at them and then
wants to go beyond them they don't do
the pointing themselves they're just
what they are and they're connected in
some way to things in themselves to
Numa and it's reason which is drawing
these
connections and being oriented by this
desire so what we find is uh the
cognition of things in themselves which
just in the next paragraph he is going
to call numina once again and he's done
that earlier in the work it's only uh in
cognition of these alone that reason can
now notice this hope to
satisfy its desire its Fair
long for completion
knite um in proceeding from the
conditioned the empirical things that we
observe to the conditions or the
conditioning the transcendental ideas
which are giving us some idea of what
the Numa the things in themselves
possibly could be but not knowledge of
what they actually are now again I've
pointed out this affective Dimension
hoping satisfying
desire these are all words that bear an
affective resonance to them so this is
well worth pointing out and thinking
about now now Kant is also going to talk
as I mentioned in the next paragraph
about the Pina what is the relation of
reason to the numina he says that the
transcendental ideas have urged us to
approach them and have led us to the
spot where the occupied space that is
experienced touches the void thein the
empty uh where uh you know that of which
we can know nothing that is numina he
says we can determine the bound BS of of
reason so the void is actually beyond
the bounds of pure reason in this case
right and um this is going to lead us
he's going to talk about the the Supreme
Being in just a moment and we're going
to talk about that a little bit later so
he tells us that we can never cognize
these beings of understanding as they
are in themselves right so we we can't
actually know know them however now he
said this a little bit earlier we must
therefore think and here he talks about
the three different uh ideas classes of
ideas because uh cosmological is plural
right of pure reason we cannot not think
those we can't get away from them at
least if we're thinkers right so he says
that
um in them only as
things in
themselves reason attains only in this
does reason find that completion and
satisfaction now notice again this term
which it can never hope for in the
derivation of appearances from their
homogeneous grounds and here again we
have the conditioned and the
conditioning or the conditions right so
reason can't avoid trying to seek out
this completion and satisfaction in the
transcendental ideas but we can't know
them we can't know the things in
themselves we can't know the
numina except well we're not knowing
them and we're not cognizing them
determinately right determining them but
we can think them as he says by means of
such Concepts as Express their
relation to the world of sense so if we
represent to ourselves he says a being
of the understanding with nothing but
pure concepts of the understanding we
represent nothing determinant to
ourselves so our concept has no
significance but if we think of it by
properties borrowed from the sensible
world it's no longer a being of
understanding but is conceived of a
phenomenon and belongs to the sensible
world so we can't make much progress
indeed any real progress except by
thinking the
numina purely in relation to the
phenomena now is that actually going to
provide reason with a completion and
satisfaction that it desires that it
Longs for that it hopes for not exactly
but it's going to get it closer than
merely resting with a adequate in itself
adequate to itself but inadequate to
reason phenomenal
world